[Music]
today on chalk radio making calculus a
little less abstract
we put together a lot of problems that
come from concepts that we see in real
life if it's connected with something
which is more real you
are more willing to work through that
i'm your host sarah hansen
calculus has an intimidating reputation
but our guest today has been
experimenting with creative new ways to
teach this complex subject
giliola staffilani is a professor of
mathematics and one of the lead
instructors of introductory course
calculus one
and she's found that with a little help
students often find calculus to be more
intuitive than they first expect
i feel like calculus actually gets
introduced without students really
knowing about it
like when they start doing algebra and
they start talking about functions and
also by watching movies documentaries
and so on you often learn about function
velocity and you learn that there is a
direction there is a magnitude which is
a speed and it's kind of like going to a
foreign country and if you just live
there for a little bit after a couple of
weeks you pick up few words
but then it's only when you actually
take a class that you put all this
together
but sometimes students get stuck in
translation when moving across
disciplines
i think
us mathematicians like to use we have a
common language like for example most
common notation for a variable is x
sometimes we ask why
the function is always an f
we're just very familiar in using that
and it's very common among
mathematicians
but i realized for example that it's not
a common notation for the same kind of
question when you
read books that comes from chemistry
in math it just you wanted to reduce
everything to a mathematical concept you
don't want to be distracted with names
and maybe cumbersome type of notation
you just don't want that to distract you
but chemistry the name of the variable
is important because you probably need
to remember what that means in within a
certain reaction or something like that
it is very hard i think for a student to
when he or she
starts taking a different class after
calculus
to
realize that actually no already what
they are supposed to know they just
think that they don't because the
notation is completely different
[Music]
to help students get grounded in the
world of calculus giliola and her
colleagues have brought visual learning
methods into the classroom
when we put together the calculus class
that we have on mitx
it was very important for us to
give a tool to the students to actually
draw pictures
in calculus
it's very important to understand the
relationship between
the formula so the analysis what we call
mathematical analysis so there is a
formula written with variables and what
that formula represents so for example
we can write a line
with an equation but we also can draw a
line and we need to understand why the
two objects are exactly the same and if
we change a parameter how that line or
other kind of curve changes
sometimes those methods might look like
a demonstration in class
one that i have used in my class at some
point which is really
very hard to grasp is lagrange
multipliers this is a method
that we use to find
maximum minimum
with constraints let's think about
sphere for example when you have
a surface that grows so the maximum
radius until the sphere touches the
boundary of a square
when that touching happens then you know
the two orthogonal vectors are going to
be parallel that's really what the
system tells you
if like me you're not a mathematician
you might be a little lost in all these
technical terms
but just wait until giliola describes
how she turns these abstract ideas into
a physical example
so i usually bring a balloon that i
start inflating and box and then when it
touches the box it's clear that the side
of the box is totally tangent to the
side of my surface and that's what the
normal vectors are orthogonal to each
other so this is
intuitively
visible and it tells you that really
these vectors are parallel so then
setting up the system becomes more like
a writing down what it means to have
these two vectors in a parallel y
instead of just remembering the
algorithm i have to take all this
derivatives that equals zero and things
like that so
it is a very important
whenever you have the opportunity to
visualize an object it is uh important
to do that
except that as
you become more and more sophisticated
in mathematics that becomes harder and
harder but whenever you can anything you
can use is good
juliola and her colleagues have
incorporated digital applets to bring
these kinds of visual representations
into learning experiences
applets are also expanding the kinds of
problems they're able to challenge
students with
so some problems are like a yes or no
question or like a
plug in a number and some other problems
in particular in calculus have some kind
of a complicated formula or a drawing or
something which is not easy to
grade or to decide whether it's correct
or not
so the sketching tool was
very important because
there are problems in calculus in which
you don't need to be extremely precise
but with a drawing you can show us
whether you understand the concept or
not but then of course my drawing might
be different than your drawing although
they're both correct they both reflect
what we ask you to do and this was a
complicated type of
problem and a very difficult problem to
grade so the sketching tool i think gave
us a way of grading questions and the
possibility to the student to solve
questions in a way which was
exactly what we want them to do instead
of
a complicated cumbersome way for us to
decide whether you understand or not
as she experiments with new teaching
tools for calculus one
gigliola has also grappled with
inequities in the field of mathematics
we thought
about
also
giving the chance the student to solve
the problem kind of like a little video
games or things like that
but it's just really complicated to to
do that we also thought that would have
been
not a fair way of
dealing with this because i think there
are studies on that
that the boys tend to do video games or
work on video game much more than girls
so if we set up something like that then
we were afraid that the girls will not
be
interested in it and so we decide not to
even go that way so to make it fair and
make it interesting for all not just for
a category of people
and as a mother she's witnessed
firsthand how biases are formed years
before students even reach the college
level
i have twins a boy and a girl and now
they are 16 and a witness from
from the time they were in middle school
how different they were treated because
one was a boy one was a girl
and the reaction that they have to the
way they are treated right so
my son for example is kind of
i wouldn't say shows off but he likes to
be taught as somebody that picks hard
classes and my daughter who
is just as good as he is and she likes
her classes but she hides it completely
she doesn't say that she's taking her
classes because that's not considered to
be attractive for a young woman or older
woman
while for boys it's okay
so there's a lot of social pressure and
also a lot of different reactions to
the behavior from the teachers
so it's very acceptable if a girls is
not really putting too much effort in
science and math
and it's less acceptable for boys
so yeah unfortunately from that early on
women young women and young men are
treated differently
and i think it really
takes a lot of effort for the young
women who wants to do more science and
more math because i think they just have
to go against very high social pressure
so then by the time i see them you know
i undergrad at mit we know it's about 49
women 51 percent men
in the math department i think it's
around 30 percent women and math major
and then when you go to grad school
there are maybe 18 20
women and when you go to faculty well
there are four of us
is there one small thing that educators
could do to try to make this situation
better
yeah i think being aware
that they themselves have implicit
biases would be already a big step
and i do have implicit biases myself i i
know that
but i'm aware of it so i'm trying to go
in the opposite direction i will
actually be tempted to go without
thinking about it so i think being aware
of the issue being aware that when you
ask a question new math class you might
be a woman teacher you look at the boys
the girls which is something that
happens very often being aware of that
that's already a big step so next time
you try to do
you know 50 50. i mean if all the
problems are about baseball players who
and soccers and well now the girl do
soccer they are even better than men so
that's great but you know
there were problems that were written 15
years ago and they were all for boys
because those those are the
people that will take those classes so
being aware of this
and what difference could make
if you just you phrase the problem you
know in a different way i think it's
very important
at the end of the day deliola hopes that
students will feel invested in the
questions they're answering in calculus
one
we put together a lot of problems that
come from concepts that we see in real
life that really helps i think also in
accepting
the difficulties that you face when you
actually have to solve a problem if it's
connected with something which is more
real you
are more willing to work through that
so for example one problem that i like
which actually has to do with solving
some linear equations is a question on
how many bagels i'm supposed to
buy and versus how many croissan and how
many if the classes want a certain you
know likes more sweets or salty or
things like that so it's a it's a simple
problem but then when you have to
translate into math and find a solution
you have to use relatively sophisticated
tools to do that if there's more than
one variable so right with an important
outcome too yeah right
i usually bring that stuff in class
afterwards crosstalk and bagels and
donuts
and then i try to say how would you
attack this how would you do this or
maybe some questions from biology or
from question from chemistry or
something that has at least the first
step which one can understand using
calculus to give the idea that this is
not like some abstract nonsense that we
force you to take at mit but it's
something that's very important to
like i said from the very beginning it's
a language that you need to acquire in
order to
attack any basic questions that might
come up in science in general which has
not already been answered right which is
something that they
love to be in the position of doing in
your new life right to answer a new
question
[Music]
if you're interested in teaching with g
leola's calculus materials head over to
mit's open learning library site where
you'll find her single variable calculus
moocs
thank you so much for listening until
next time signing off from cambridge
massachusetts i'm your host sarah hansen
from mit open courseware
mit chalk radio's producers include
myself brett pache and dave lashansky
our script writers are nidhishastri and
aubry callaway
show notes for this episode were written
by peter chipman
we're funded by mit open learning and
supporters like you
you